l'égérie d'ailleurs on s'est amusé à
chercher votre sosie sur les réseaux
sociaux à la télé si vous devez être
remplacé regardez on a vu gilles verdez
garder tes copains avec michel edouard
leclerc
on a vu isabelle qui nous l'avait cachée
elle a bien connu charly chaplin
kelly mais devenir gardé elle s'appelle
meghan mccain apparemment elle et
qu'elle a la frite benhaim on l'a vu
dans chasseur d'appartement castany on
la croisait après leur a fait son 1500
pour regarder géraldine magnin on l'a vu
du peu de réflexion l'ex gone away ce
qu'il faut mettre les céréales avant ou
après le lait regardez jean pascal nous
avait caché sa passion pour la muscu et
la coupe mulet regarder voilà on a jean
michel may rossy qui était dans le métro
tranquille apparemment guillaume genton
il a passé son week-end avec bernard
montiel mis la partition
regardez moi j'étais tranquille devant
crime hier